remember on the left was all about love
peace and understanding oh come on you
remember all those great musical numbers
at those no nukes concerts back in the
late 70s the early 80s like Jackson
Browne I mean this was awesome time well
the less thought we should stop being so
belligerent toward the Soviet Union we
should engage with the Soviets all for a
better world
now some even admired the Castros in
Cuba and they flirted with Marxist
ideology here at home so one would have
thought that many of those same people
and their ideological offspring would
view president Trump's summit with Kim
jong-un as a moment to savor a real
chance at creating a more peaceful
planet but no and you know why because
the man doing the outreach and
negotiating is Donald J Trump before
during and after his whirlwind trip to
Singapore for the Kim meeting his
critics in both parties kept revealing
themselves their narratives if you
notice kept shifting six months ago it
was this lack of a diplomatic and
serious engagement strategy in my view
has us sliding toward war by next summer
Trump's comments about nuclear weapons
have experts worried he could literally
inadvertently trigger a catastrophe
warning that his reckless behavior could
launch the nation on the path to World
War three you are all wrong every one of
you we don't have enough time to list
you all we're wrong but this tyranny of
being wrong by the experts is nothing
new because after all they were wrong
about the election of Donald Trump the
economy of Donald Trump the pro-life
commitment of Donald Trump and the
trade policies of Donald Trump just to
name a few so naturally as the summit
began the error caucus offered this
trench and analysis Donald Trump can
relate to authoritarians he as a former
businessman he likes absolute control
and we do want to be despot i i've
conceded that for years now it's really
interesting because the more we're
talking about north korea you know the
like the less we're talking about russia
this is not just a meeting about foreign
policy this is about Donald Trump's
political survival that's their midterm
message that's all they've got what is
that that's all they've got
says the woman who brought us the
winning campaign of John McCain and in
2008 okay so I guess record low
unemployment a thriving economy tax cuts
the destruction of Isis and now a
foreign policy coup that has eluded
multiple administration's is all they've
got
but even after Trump brought Kim to
Singapore even after he squeezed
concessions and at least a commitment to
denuclearize the Korean Peninsula the
left still will not give him a shred of
credit well Donald Trump the real estate
developer and he doesn't realize that
that this dictator doesn't want Beach
condos he he wants nuclear weapons empty
words potentially empty words and lots
of flags and lots of ceremony don't
necessarily lead to the consequences
that we hope for are we going ahead with
just some hopeful wishful
and I find that incredibly worrying
incredibly depressing there's no snow
knowledge of history it's staggering to
everyday to realize how unselfish a lack
of knowledge
I don't recall most of these same media
elites griping about embracing dictators
when Barack Obama restored ties with the
Castros in Cuba when he gave hundreds of
millions of dollars to the dictators in
Iran for a bogus denuclearization deal
or when he held a state dinner for the
Chinese dictator the Selective moral
outrage here is galling predictable and
oh so blatant when Trump talks tough
they say he's a war monger taking us
right to war but when he gets bad guys
to sit at the negotiating table and
begin to hammer out a peace framework he
savaged for embracing a dictator so
which is it guys they beat him up for
saying that he trusts Kim that Kim
actually wants to make a change but
Trump himself said listen carefully he
could be wrong I think honestly I think
he's gonna do these things I may be
wrong yeah he said I don't have to come
back and pologize I wouldn't like it
though and let's face it even with the
high stakes high stakes involved here
really serious possibly deadly
consequences of failure President Trump
makes geopolitics fun again I may stand
before you in six months and say hey I
was wrong I don't know that I'll ever
admit that but I'll find us I'll find
some kind of an excuse Ooka maybe even
some of the doubters had to laugh a
little bit have some fun this is a great
time to be an American like who else
could have gotten us to this point I
mean he said openly and he said it to a
couple of reporters that were with him
that he knows that no other president
ever could have done this well okay so
he's got a big ego what president
doesn't big deal isn't Trump's path
better than the alternative that the
elites were warning us about
six months ago I mean at North Korea
that is so isolated that it might think
to do the unthinkable hit an American
city with an ICBM so I say let him
distract us all they like let him keep
going the flapping their lips about this
let him lie and contradict their own
analyses while their audience and
readership shrink and they basically
just tune them out more Americans I
think are seeing through the media
manipulation and Trump both at home and
abroad is undeterred by their static
he's too busy winning and that's the
angle